[Music]
in Florida women news submitted by
caffeine to fish
I see three naked women led police on a
wild car chase yeah what's the fish
gefilte fish I don't know it was in that
movie yeah he was trying to talk about
it you couldn't say it was that one line
that Chris Tucker couldn't say and then
Jackie Chan was making fun of him like I
don't even speak English I remember the
face why don't you say it I remembered
that on the airplane I'll take your
spleen I remember that part in the alt
tags but I remember that line I think
they just cut it out well it's not gonna
get the [ __ ] line yeah so these three
women they let a wild police chase do we
have pictures of these suspects so we
can get a picture of these three naked
sisters picture a Florida woman Cuban
girls in Miami well you know they always
go Florida man watermelon some
cracked-out guy oh I saw a fat guy with
a fanny pack in a Grand Canyon hat
Taurus mmm I know a lot of people from
Florida actually yeah yeah a real
Florine like Megan Bouton's from Florida
from Florida woman mm-hmm
swamp lady I think Kelsey who's on later
is from Florida oh yeah me too
oh my god Harry Potter world no just a
small one no what did Disney row I never
been I've been a Florida never been a
busy land but you've been Harry Potter
worlds here and then you went to Florida
go to Disney World and you didn't go to
there know exactly who you are I was
young and Harry Potter wasn't around you
oh I see did you order and Ready's
matter the goecart Arkady went to one
place what happy here
these three women they were nude um so
why do we know why they were nude
yeah so they were at this rest stop and
they said oh and I said that they so
please approach them because they got
called like dispatched out there because
of these women and so they told police
that they had showered and they were
air-drying oh I know that message
I bet European know they just get a
spray tan no definitely not
were they in a convertible no they
weren't motion-picture
I'm picturing three hot girls butt ass
naked in a convertible I pictured like
sunglasses on this thing I pictured
later in their annoying oh yeah I
picture like fifty six year olds yeah
well you're right there are the ones
that are always at the nude beach though
age you think you want to see hot people
butt-ass naked and you just see that
wrinkled testicles yeah old man trying
to see it's all daddies trying to see
millennia a lot of that I can't wait
till I'm 50 I'm gonna go naked
everywhere why don't you do it now
okay what's the paper would pay me for
my dick I take so many pictures oh this
way that's where they on paper a you're
giving away I got my first dick pic on
Instagram do your first one
congratulation has blocked him
immediately we need you hit the blur and
then you still wanted to see more bye
why are you blocking him though I feel
like she got the satisfaction because he
knows that you saw yeah yep he wins yeah
that's true cuz if he said that and he's
always checking yeah and in forever
he'll just forget but then it said you
block his like she saw bad dick it was
so big it made her intimidated that's
what they're thinking make me feel dirty
yeah why don't you see you don't on
snapchat because they didn't blur them
on snapchat I used to save them and then
wait for the next one to come in I send
them the last person's dick pic but they
but they didn't care
someone said you a dick you send them a
dick last person that send me a dick pic
oh you had verdict in years ago I
deleted them after I got to send them
but yes it was a lot of work and then it
didn't really have the results I wanted
because they really didn't care I'm
afraid of looking at other dick pics or
dick pics in journal because when I am
having sex I don't want that ugly ass
dick to like pop into my head whatever
do that when you're humming like
something will pop on your head you know
you should be thinking about and you're
like stop it no yeah sometimes pretty in
a moment
oh I'm not I have sex a TD if I have a
TD no I just shoot yeah yeah so like I
know you're being I know yeah
I'm masturbator on adderall ones oh my
god I was wrong after we [ __ ]
masturbated for four hours straight yeah
like suck it in do you lose track of
time often I never been diagnosed itself
diagnosed studies test I saw the thing
on you post on story out of ten so I
read a book I'm reading a book called
like living with ADHD or whatever [ __ ] I
did you read the book I know how you
feel I know how you took me a long time
I read my first book when I was 23 years
old
so I mean 22 I'm reading up a th deed
living or whatever whatever right is
this book I probably passed the first
like introduction I didn't even pass the
whole book but they're just criteria
like every time I'm starting to read it
I'm like I'm all over this I'm so bored
in figures you're not into the content
yeah yeah when you're going to it you'll
finish it ya know because I have been
reading books recently that I
into their content but then I just like
I get distracted I know I used to take
out of college I'll just delete this and
I was a kid oh really I don't know I was
never diagnosed but I knew they would
help me study and i wouldnt have to go
to class so then when i came out here I
was like I mean let me try to get at her
out prescription so I like thought I
faked the symptoms this is like five
years ago to get prescription got
subscription how do you do doctor two
months ago and he like asked me all
these questions where I was like yes
like and my answer to everything was
like holy [ __ ] he's like yep you had
ADHD and I was like I do not I totally
did and it makes so much sense every
childhood I'll share the book with you
he's like did you talk to talk out in
the middle of class did you constantly
get in trouble when you were a kid for
talking out I was like yes yes yeah so
what's the point about you sure thing
about this book that you can't remember
the [ __ ] tight on you didn't finish
your sentence what was a little point of
that okay so for adult 80 deep right you
only need six or seven out of ten
criteria in order to be considered I
have ten out of ten explained to you
what was going on gay let me tell you
about these three naked women remember
yeah okay so I've been trying to help
you tip thank you Joe so once the cops
are called
they it was like the Florida Highway
Patrol they arrived
and then they ended up jumping into
their white 2009 Nissan Sentra and fled
and then so the trooper pursued them but
then he cancelled the pursue because a
quote the do to the pursuit not fitting
SHP criteria whatever that means
so then we left then the citizen
reported a vehicle have been driving on
the wrong side of the road with the book
yeah they're on PCP for sure a different
trooper caught up with that car and
observe reckless driving and so that's
when the that trooper followed them to a
convenience store and they were naked
appendage is earning what they don't
mention if they're still naked at this
point but they were naked at the
beginning
No yeah so then the they found the car
empty and so they waited for these girls
to come out and then two of the women
got into the car he attempted to arrest
a third and he couldn't so they ended up
all jumping back into the car and then
it just was crazy i pursuit yeah so then
this other passenger got out a metal bat
and tried to assault of going and then
that's when the trooper realized that
this other man was in danger so you
rammed into a suspects car with the
patrol car it sounds like three people
streaming on GTA and then all three
suspects got out of the car and like
they fled and then they ended up getting
to this I don't know let me just show
you the freakin video oh there's a video
that's a slow chase I was jogging that's
keeping up with them are they gonna stop
soon
oh he's gonna pull a maneuver
oh that is kind of dumb yes dangerous
all the fell off that's not gonna make
me want to come out what if they can't
get out cuz they're all like crippled
from that crash yeah so then baby
started teasing these girls what this
whole thing what were they I wonder if
it went straight to the nipple like that
so was the car was driven by an 18 year
old and the two passengers were a 19
year old oh it makes the story hot again
they're triplets 18 1991 the one on the
left could be pretty the middle one I
would like I don't know what gender it
looks like the frying pan lady oh are we
sure my another video I'm a different
video sorry looks yeah pretty people
don't get taste but they all got taste
because they refuse cuz they started
like locking arms to not get out of the
car thank you why were they fighting it
so hard yeah no they were naked and then
they just bled this sounds like some
bath salt behavior yeah they're high as
[ __ ] they didn't mention any sorry but
make it teach me face the charges that
they face is fleeing to elude resisting
arrest aggravated assault and lewd
behavior that's crazy dude can you
imagine being high off [ __ ] like and
then you're going through this chase you
get [ __ ] I could never dude I would
be too paranoid and you're naked the
whole time I think I'd be smile
and laughing the whole time like this is
[ __ ] crazy sober though mmm
completely sober doing all this they're
sober they weren't of no one sane is
doing this you're in a dream world yeah
you're definitely in a dream world like
no one does this like I don't know like
it would make more sense if they if they
robbed the place then they used
nakedness as a distraction and they're
getting away
like there's no logic behind it it's
just it's straight of drugs yeah
[Music]